[Aplausos]
buenas noches
quién de ustedes ha donado ingresos
económicos en una plataforma de función
colectivo para apoyar alguna iniciativa
de un emprendedor social cuántos de
ustedes han firmado alguna petición para
apoyar alguna causa
cuántas veces al día ustedes generan y
comparten contenido positivo en sus
redes sociales
si ustedes realizan algunas de estas
acciones les tengo una excelente noticia
ustedes son activistas digitales
y para que ustedes lo puedan lograr y
luchar por estas causas tenemos a los
activistas todoterreno esos activistas
que se levantan cada día y que trabajan
por causas
estas personas tienen sueños
y todo comienza con un sueño
cuando yo era pequeña y tenía seis años
yo soñaba con ser astronauta
por el trabajo de mi papá ingeniero de
minas lo cambiaron a la isla de san
marcos ubicada en la península de baja
california sur jugando con mis amigos
llegamos a las casas de los ingenieros y
estaban cambiando los electrodomésticos
y resulta que estaban colocándolos en un
barranco
para todo ser una estufa simplemente
para mí era una cápsula espacial y lo
que yo hice fue meterme en esa estufa
cerrar la puerta
y empezar a despegar
yo estaba soñando que estaba entre
planetas entre estrellas de repente se
empezó a mover esa estufa y resulta que
en el exterior mis amigos le estaban
moviendo
la movieron tanto que lamentaron por
esto arranco
yo solo sentí como empecé a dar vueltas
y vueltas y vueltas adentro de esa
estufa no sé cuánto tiempo pasó entré en
pánico por supuesto
se detuvo
me rescataron me sacaron de la estufa
con algunos raspones nada más y ese día
aprendí dos cosas bien importantes la
primera que las estufas no se pueden
abrir por dentro y la segunda que son
tan seguras que protegen todo lo que
ponemos en nuestro interior
crecí y tenía que estudiar algo
me encantaban las matemáticas y las
computadoras pero era una niña y pro
vertida no hablaba mucho
y decidí a estudiar una carrera donde no
me relacionaba con personas donde
estuviera frente a una computadora
desarrollando líneas de código
y así estudia ingeniería en sistemas
cuando termine mis estudios
universitarios tuve la oportunidad de
entrar a trabajar en una institución de
gobierno encargada a resolver los
problemas ambientales y ahí fue donde
conocí los sistemas de información
geográfica esa forma mágica de
complementar las bases de datos con el
componente geográfico puntos líneas y
polígonos que se pueden integrar en un
sistema y que facilita la toma de
decisiones
a la par empezó a surgir ese gusanito
activista y con unos amigos formamos una
organización empezamos a dar charlas de
educación ambiental participamos en
foros participamos en talleres y todo
ese trabajo activista nos llevó a ocupar
un cargo dentro del consejo consultivo
para el desarrollo sustentable de mi
país
y estábamos en el espacio de
participación ciudadana más importante
de méxico interactuando con más de 300
consejeros de todo el país
activistas investigadores con más de 20
y 30 años de experiencia y expertos en
todos los temas ambientales y ahí
fue donde surgió la gran idea
qué pasaría
si construyéramos una red de gestión del
conocimiento donde todos compartiéramos
información generamos datos abiertos
pero además nos permitiera difundir y
dar a conocer todas las actividades que
se estaban haciendo en cualquier estado
de la república
empezamos diseñando un prototipo local
que en pocos meses se convirtió en
regional y en menos de un año se
convirtió en la plataforma oficial de
vinculación del consejo consultivo
era una plataforma que estaba
sincronizada en tiempo real con todas
las páginas que teníamos en redes
sociales también incluye un módulo
cartográfico con bases de datos
geográficas por supuesto libres de
descarga
y lo más interesante es que incluye un
directorio georeferenciado de todas las
personas que formábamos parte de ese
consejo y el sector al que
representábamos mujeres jóvenes
organizaciones sin fines de lucro
empresarios académicos
ir un paso más allá porque los sueños
nunca se terminan
y como nos dimos cuenta que la mayoría
de las personas tienen teléfonos
inteligentes se nos ocurrió la brillante
idea de desarrollar una aplicación móvil
la desarrollamos pensando que iba a ser
el mayor logro de nosotros y de ese
consejo lamentablemente tuvimos menos de
10 descargas y entonces fue cuando nos
dimos cuenta que no porque la mayoría de
las personas tengan un teléfono
inteligente significa que son personas
que están acostumbradas a usar
aplicaciones móviles es por esa razón
que las tiendas están saturadas de
aplicaciones que nadie descarga y cuando
a mí alguien me pregunta que si es
conveniente desarrollar una aplicación
lo primero que les digo es tienes que
analizar si tu usuario es una persona
que está acostumbrada a usar
aplicaciones móviles
después de esta etapa de la aplicación
gracias a todo este trabajo que hicimos
con la red llega la convocatoria un
premio nacional ambiental y nos invitan
a formar parte del jurado calificador y
nos toca evaluar más de 50 proyectos de
activistas ambientales de todo el país
mucho trabajo de campo años y años de
investigaciones
pero tenían una debilidad muy grande no
se veía reflejado todo ese trabajo en
sus perfiles de redes sociales pocas
organizaciones cuentan con páginas
propias y la mayoría desconocen que
existen mecanismos de fondeo y
plataformas de donaciones donde pueden
obtener ingresos de cualquier parte del
mundo
además de soñar mucho soy activista
he adoptado los mejores puntos de los
hackers que son compartir conocimiento
generar datos abiertos usar software
libre con lo que implica ser una persona
activista que lucha por causas y que día
a día tenemos que hacer que esos grandes
cambios que necesitamos sucedan
mi gran causa soy fundadora de mentoría
4.0 una comunidad de mentores y
emprendedores
que concordamos
en que las grandes oportunidades las van
a brindar los puntos claves de la
industria 4.0 internet de las cosas
ciberseguridad
impresión 3 de realidad virtual realidad
aumentada robótica servicios en la nube
entre otros y que les apoyamos a los
emprendedores en dos aspectos bien
importantes el primero que detecta en un
problema
generen una solución y busquen impactar
en cualquiera de los son indicadores del
bienestar diseñados por la ocde y la
segunda que construyan empresas sociales
que generen ingresos recurrentes
una comunidad donde lo más importante no
es que te conviertas en millonario el
éxito real y el impacto es que tú logres
cambiar la vida de las personas
en la actualidad vivimos en un mundo
inmerso en tecnología redes sociales
hemos perdido la convivencia humana y
quiero citar esta frase de albert
eisntein tengo el día en que la
tecnología sobrepase nuestra humanidad
el mundo sólo tendrá una generación de
idiotas y yo los invito a que la
transformemos en algo como lo siguiente
no temo el día en que la tecnología
sobrepase la humanidad el mundo tendrá
una generación de ciudadanos
inteligentes ciudadanos proactivos
ciudadanos que luchan por causas
ciudadanos que ayuden a otros ciudadanos
tal vez
no cambiemos tantos problemas que
existen pero cada una de nuestras
acciones diarias pueden hacer esa gran
diferencia no nos cuesta nada
generar y compartir contenido positivo
en nuestras redes sociales no nos cuesta
nada firmar una petición en una
plataforma tecnológica cuántos pesos nos
puede costar apoyar el proyecto de un
emprendedor social
tal vez no construyamos ese mundo
perfecto pero estoy segura que podemos
mejorarlo y el día de hoy yo estoy aquí
para que cada una de sus causas se
conviertan en mis causas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]